it's just pretty amazing that we get to  see it in our lifetime not many people  have  and it's  just spectacular to see Mauna Loa  longest mountain in the world to finally  erupt and  Pele doing her magic  so that's it's pretty spectacular  knowing the history and you know friends  and family on the island it's it's just  pretty special to have this eruption  we're just glad it's in this vicinity  and not  affecting any communities the scary  thing is lava flows from Mauna Loa can  reach any side of the island and she is  a massive volcano  um but it's a humbling experience to get  to see once in a lifetime potentially  opportunity  to see how long this eruption lasts and  and if there's another one who knows  when that will be